[Music]
how's it going bros minute peter pack
welcome to there is no game i feel like
i played this already
but it came out this year and i want to
check it out so
look i i definitely haven't played it i
just recognized the title
uh do i quit what happens if i quit this
way
quit yes or no no right
okay yes
[Laughter]
all right no what the [ __ ]
all right good game 10 out of 10. thanks
for watching guys are you serious i got
played that quick
i had to maybe didn't i i bet i bet i'm
the only one that went out on that one
quit no oh i gotta hit no game here
come on sake all right so
what is this
can't even get it to the first level
yes huge thank you to everyone for
supporting the arcade indiegogo campaign
it was a huge success to say the least
look at this thing
it's beautiful now as a popular demand
this thing now works with pc games top
pc games
i'm talking call of duty doom
gotta try this baby on doom pubg
valorent
you name it okay we don't have every
game but a ton of games
so the blaster now works with geforce
now which is very cool
it also works with pc it has a ton of
library of android games
this is a new way to play we're bringing
it to you so
the product is now available at
arcade.games
the website itself is very cool check it
out
honestly but you also get 10 off if you
enter the code
pewdiepie to get one of these bad boys
so yeah link is in the description
check it out
when this icon appears exit the program
immediately to maximize your performance
of corrupting
uh it's not like this non-game has a
hint system so there's no reason to
click on the ike
okay so it's a puzzle game good thing
i am extremely large brain there should
be no
issues since no not i've been way
smarter i've been feeling it
all right pulling this no problem there
we go
god damn i'm smart but that took
jacksepticeye three years
my mizun mizon ibm is that french
who's doing all this knocking is someone
there's someone in here
just a minute please where's my speech
oh here it is
i almost forget the title
don't panic don't panic
hey we made it to the title screen
that feels good hello thank you this is
a program speaking
i've got some bad news actually there's
no game
the financial crisis in depocades
probably love this
i hope you're not too disappointed you
can still watch
tv i'm starting to think he's foolish
but i am really
here there is no game but just between
you and me
avoid asking for a refund if you can
out of a refund
you know my creator has got to eat and
feed his
12 kids not my problem
and his wife who is sick
couldn't count once when he
[Music]
is that thing going to hold no it's
holding well it's been fun but
i'm getting down
my title oh my god
hey that's so cool whoa
great the break breaker game of the year
best bet this took markiplier three
years
[Applause]
i'm crapping victory well if that's the
way things are going to be
let's make something solid
oh okay
hello
[Music]
what
the next one's yours i just know it
oh that's too bad you lost again don't
give up
solve that so quick i bet you i'm the
speed run master of this game
luckily i thought of everything to
protect the game
game has to be an error right here
finished
that's why we're going to stop now and
you're going to leave
happy to have played
are you crazy
[Music]
yeah so smart dude next
level wait what get out of here
what is this this is backstage you
should not be here
you're going to catch cold what can i do
with this back to the title correction
my ex title okay that has to be
something with these then
everything is broken i can change the
paper
draw me a go
draw me a cog don't stop messing around
trying to fix
anything you won't get far without a
screwdriver
i need a screwdriver this is a
screwdriver you're still here
you're a pro at taking things apart
weird okay
i solved the puzzle before i knew what
the puzzle was
that's how big brain this is i know
you're amazed
i know you're sitting there how can you
be so clever no no no
need a key all right
so the cog wheel goes here not welcome
am i dreaming or are you trying to pick
the lock with the mouse cursor
that's on my side onto the floor
there we go so we pushed the rug under
the classic right
where did you find that key
okay i did something all right
what the [ __ ] do i do would i put that
underneath okay
under the door i don't understand what
you're doing
there we go see i'm i'm telling you guys
this is too easy for me
i hope this will calm you down
what do we got here it looks like it
needs a cog all right we have one
uh i need another one stop
moving from screen to screen my system
doesn't like that
you're going to saturate it
okay oh there's a cover there i didn't i
saw it last second
we're back in the game i meant the nun
game let's not do that again okay
the ram is saturated again yeah
so smart big brain feels good
bent jack had to look up a tutorial i
don't like that
yeah but i like it
jamie there's nothing left i can use to
help me
too bad i have no choice let's go let's
go let's go
okay but where
program loading what bad luck
you were able to press the button i'm
very upset
no the program is loading and there's
nothing i can do to stop it
you're good you've beaten me yep
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yeah it definitely crashed
nope
the program is going to close due to an
unexpected use
error program closing
what the [ __ ] is this the progress
please restart the machine this is my
operating system
flying squirrel always what timeline is
this
you need to restart your machine and
this is not a fake
pretty neat anywhere and you should not
open the prohibited folder
for any reason oh i didn't even see that
sky
zin whip all right well he's got a key
so
he wants uh uh nut all right where
should the nut be
i have no friends enlarge your
memory memory bar only 99
hell yeah oh uh i am a lonely processor
find love
okay what's in the trash
private do not shake all right
and your conscience is telling you that
you definitely shouldn't
miss it did we see a number somewhere we
saw it before
oh don't shake he said right
[Music]
so cool
[Laughter]
no all right truth the truth about
roswell hello dude the technical problem
the content of this document has
unfortunately been lost sorry the fbi
ps oh yes i was a weather brother
it was a weather balloon super private
the trivia kennedys
the shooter was a weather balloon ultra
private the truth of apollo
hello gigabyte
hey
okay it is no nut but uh
huh i can flip it
oh got a call not me greetings
you don't know me
i just wanted to say that these pictures
are scandalous
i'm going to contact the authorities
right away regarding the classification
of this game
non-game and they are not mine it's for
a friend
there okay we got an opener
that's so cool you can change the song
all right let's go over this one maybe
this can open the trash
it could worst pinball ever
okay is this a mini game
i gotta beat the high score right the
ice core is going to be bitten
that's better are you serious
wait
okay yeah
let's go cheat there yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah all right i forgot the
administrative password entering this
order spot the odd one out on my id card
okay
my your favorite number miss tokyo's
private number that was four
eight four uh so we start with the spot
the odd one io and then his favorite
number
i don't think we figured out the
favorite number yet maybe it's in here
game i have to leave sorry geeky oh
there it is eight
okay okay and then his favorite number
here you want a reward
we haven't done the win zip yet it makes
it bigger
or smaller oh my god he was there it was
on his skype profile
okay cool
uh-huh now we just need water we can
probably fill this up somehow
maybe play the music we are playing it's
telling
[Music]
all right give me the acorn there it is
sweet that's dope
what you want to break it now uh
oh my god there's a nutcracker are you
serious
i forgot about that
nice yeah i solved it before you did
shut up
okay i don't need what do i do with the
key i forgot all right prohibited right
you gotta make it smaller first
okay all
[Applause]
don't do that
[Music]
should i be worried what's on that disc
sorry i have a mustache i'm ready for
anything
[Laughter]
yes this is the program speaking
i have some bad news actually this is
not a game
i hope you are not too disappointed you
can still watch a bollywood film
what this is my game i mean mine on game
what are you talking about go away you
should not be here
but usually i gotta do something damn it
you have a funny accent
are you russian russian do i wrote the r
like that sir of course not user you
need to quit the program
first i'm begging you
hi guys don't touch him user
he is highly unstable the only one who's
unstable around here
is you game i told you not to touch him
user
i did it i'm so smart
wow incredible
no one's figured this one out that
markiplier uses hints
cringe
this one truly has a russian accent ah
you see
but you're still here it seems to be
your game
you are show me papers only if you say
please
it's changed again
[Music]
this game is so [ __ ] weird i'm
begging you stop being hanged and sick
with him
you're going to get us killed we are all
going to die
no you shut up
[Music]
if there's a swedish one my mind will be
blown
[Music]
okay damn what the [ __ ]
all right i like this it's fun i
remember back in the day
so when people actually did let's play
some of my favorite ones to watch were
possible games what
what happened i
think i went to sleep for a minute
some kind of television what the [ __ ] is
this
gives us different number combinations
but we don't know for what yet
you plugged in the video input i know
i'm not smart oh you just couldn't help
yourself could you
oh cool so this is the side of the tv
ghost possession faulty guys
kisses from the gear factory thank you
gear factory
i feel like it kind of pains me to break
stuff
even if it's a game
i've already done it am i missing an
obvious crack here
yo what the [ __ ] is this
old-school video games holy [ __ ] don't
tell me you've broken another no way
what is it adventure island whatever
it's called i forgot
no wait it isn't i'm ninny collins but
the style looks like it
is it me or is there an echo all of a
sudden
i used to love charlotte collins when i
was younger i read all his book as a kid
affirmative there was nothing human
about that scream
it seems to be coming from our dear
neighbor wilhelm's home
we are trapped in this world just like
this fictional character
oh sure all right well we have this
possible to tell what's real
and what's an illusion now we must avoid
running into the sk
did you take off one of the game's icons
or the one with the bent corner
sure just what do you plan to do with
that feast uh
bro fist of course in my mouth rufus in
my eye
brother's in my uh okay what do we do
with the fist i don't know we'll figure
it out
oh okay found it
when i asked you to find a way out i was
talking about this dimension
mr wilhelm open the door it's your
neighbor
sherlock holmes so cool i love their
homes
what we need is a key you disappoint me
my dear friend
be more creative make more daring
associations
and think in four dimensions oh they're
telling us aren't they
like you're doing now
oh i'm supposed to hit that
a lost penny it's my lucky day
okay oh lucky evening my friend
i cut the paper hey
it's mine now nice homes
i have the impression that there is
whispering going on around us
a sort of voice with a russian accent
but i'm not there did you hear it
it's romanian anything i heard is the
gentle rustling of the wind
with a russian accent
all right we got a coin now we can
unlock these maybe
yeah i certainly have a thing for
tinkerine
that's not a good idea user no
oh god what is that it
looks like the set of the game but soon
from the other side
no way what the [ __ ] is happening so
this is i need to open for them right
so what can i do to interact with this
maybe move this somehow
yeah how does that look if i move it
why i know what you're going to do don't
you
dare go help them out i need to break
that
you're already retaining that's
so weird i've gotten the better of this
door
so i can follow them here mr wilhelm
are you there what in the [ __ ]
is that oh yeah the we need this
there we go let's just tear everything
down and what are you going wow
are you trying to stick a stamp to that
device at first
to stick your stamp to something you
need to get it wet oh thanks for the
attempt
oh we gotta lick it right
and then we go back and we hit the
switch
nice
oh yeah oh yeah
whoa i knew it well done watson we can
finally see better
uh oh wow i've already made it way past
in less time
whatever living daylight i knew it big
brainer
bigger brain mark sorry
holmes he's floating
scream that's what that sound effect is
called that's a nice little reference
there
once you hear it once you hear it in so
many movies
i swear to god i watched twilight don't
judge me and they put
in wilhelm's scream in there if you were
thinking about moving that fake wall
forget about it on the ground
wow wow i love that
but that doesn't make any sense you
might as well use i don't know
a monkey to work a hydraulic pump but
what really gets me is
that it works that's so fun this game
so where did that go
you just swiped their mining glass i
don't know how i did that but i did it
for you let's see if we can figure this
one out
one more rule you're going to be able to
break oh i can just press it okay
[Music]
okay
i told you i had my magnifying glasses i
just had to go back
and it suddenly disappeared there you go
they're figuring out
the russian ghost but i'm not russian
my name is game
i'm a computer program i'm so it is a
game
there is no game your game
you are aware that the world you're in
isn't real
not you just like you are of course as
well
you don't know that you're in a video
game is that it i'd rather look for my
magnifying glass than continue listening
to your mad jabbering mr wilhelm
it's just pixel porridge
well we have the phone number on
the thing right finally
damn it took so long to use this five
five two three six eight
back in my day we used to have phones
like this you know
it works there's a connection that's
strange
a disenchantment ritual you'll have to
find another dupe madam
goodbye was it a video game
no a telephone scam this channel combs
fellow is not very copyrighted
that's not very nice is that it mind you
nothing you do not surprises me anymore
and now again
over in this corner i say there's a bit
of light over by the entrance
my magnifying glass here well done user
that character isn't by the
communication device anymore
i think you're going to have to answer
mr watson
the russian video games
very well speed run
it's like coffee on top oh you a video
game too
yes i don't like watson's mustache just
super clear here
even though i have one on my all right
true okay so behind the scenes here
these kinds of paints we can paint that
nice
like a juicy cheese do you think it will
do the
trick yes let's hope so
now how do we get the ice cream
the user thank you thank you
really that's so lame some of these
puzzles are lame
this is like oh you happen to be on that
screen like
come on we go
well done jim no
no are you serious
oh my god
[Music]
okay all right okay
all right all right this is a weird
[ __ ] game all right we got the snow
there you go we got you sorry mr wilhelm
it's for your own
good i think they're not even
questioning it
all right so we got the cherry i forgot
what the last thing i was supposed to do
was they never
have to call again to see i forgot this
tongue as a brush
is that the right color yeah that's the
right color gray then
green and red green and red everyone
done
yeah hell yeah
[Applause]
watson mr wilhelm just exploded like a
beached whale
i'm finally free of that it's the same
boy
i can tell guys i'm that smart mr glitch
you again did you follow me we were
transported here by
accident we no it can't be
all right well gg guys no
we have to follow him do not touch this
piece
that's it that was it now the painting
is the right way round
at least i think so where are you trying
to go mr glitch
to a place where i will be able to
unleash my evil plan
what plan
a copy protection system right in the
middle of the game
how barbaric we're missing the
explanation of his evil plan
let's find the numbers we need fast user
wow so we can change those
315.
i'm too smart for this game come on what
an
evil plan isn't it could you say that
again
we got cut off no there i just saw the
exit
which means this is where we say goodbye
markiplier didn't make it this far
oh [ __ ] god damn it
farewell rainbow butterfly oh he didn't
solve it oh i took him ages
ah it took him aj okay
all right kane and bomb kane bomb
okay pain bomb 6.5 wait
uh there's clearly a problem
he still hasn't solved it
no no no no this is fine so that looks
like a five
ah goddamn that don't look like a
[Laughter]
oh yeah i bet mark doesn't know what to
do because i
i know what to do yeah i know what to do
we need to
get the moon back and we get the string
and then we can drop a oh easy
and do this and move it again
oh yeah but mark didn't figure that out
impossible impossible
hey we can go down there's the exit yeah
i'm going to fall hold on watson
the world is ending everything is fake
i am fake they've been enlightened
we can't leave them there like that
to the bathtub right mark there's a
manhole
there you go it wasn't that hard no it
wasn't
we just opened the passage for you
wow wow he
cut it means you can figure it out
i'm just naming mark by the way it's
just for fun hold on watson
we're going to swing over to the hole
three two
one well done holmes
while drawing anyone
now that they're safe we can leave huge
break
wow what a trip dude it took me 10
minutes to do that
uh the whole game of course pretty easy
i would say
pretty easy game legend of the
secret all right
i'm toast thanks for watching maybe i'll
do another one if you guys want me to it
was really fun thanks for joining
all of you subscribed subscribe now it's
free it's epic and i'll see you guys
tomorrow with another video
thanks for watching brofist
[Music]